sharks have been celebrated as powerful
guides by some native cultures for
example Fijians believe the shark god
deca Wonga could protect fishermen from
the dangers at sea and today sharks are
recognized as apex predators of the
world's ocean and include some of the
earth's longest living vertebrates what
is it that makes these fish worthy of
our ancient legends and so successful in
the seas much of their hunting prowess
stems from a unique set of biological
traits honed for more than 400 million
years their cartilaginous skeletons are
less dense than bony ones and require
less energy to move large oily livers
blend buoyancy to their streamlined
bodies and while trunk muscles of bony
fishes attach directly to their
skeletons those of sharks also join to
their skin this special design
transforms them into pressurized tubes
whose springy skin can efficiently
transmit muscular forces to the tail
shark skin has additional remarkable
features
despite its smooth external appearance
at the micro level it has a coarse
texture
thanks to thousands of tiny teeth like
scales called dermal denticles each
tentacle is coated in a substance called
enamel oeid which turns the skin into a
tough shield plus the structure of
denticles varies across the body in such
a way as to reduce noise and drag when
the shark moves through water as for the
teeth in their mouths
sharks can produce up to 50,000 in a
lifetime on average they can lose one to
the week and each time that happens it's
rapidly replaced thanks to a layer of
fluoride coating their teeth sharks also
avoid cavities but teeth aren't the same
in all sharks they can vary across
species and by diet some are dense and
flattened useful for crushing mollusks
others are needle-like for gripping fish
the amounts of great whites contain
pointy lower teeth for holding prey and
triangular serrated upper teeth for
slicing
this variety enables trucks to target
prey in a diversity of ocean
environments many species also have
another peculiar trait the ability to
launch their jaws out of their mouths
open them extra wide and grab prey by
surprise over the course of evolution
shark brains have expanded coupled with
the growth of their sensory organs
modern-day sharks can smell a few drops
of blood and hear sounds underwater from
800 meters away they're particularly
well tuned to low frequencies including
those emitted by dying fish and light
cats they have reflective membranes
called tappa de Luci de at the backs of
their eyes that dramatically improve
their vision in low-light as if these
heightened abilities weren't enough
sharks have even hone of success they're
able to hunt using a network of electro
sensory cells called ampullae of
Lorenzini these cells are filled with
hypersensitive jelly which allows them
to detect electrical signals from prey
including the slightest twitch of a
muscle some of the most iconic shark
species like great whites Makos poor
beagles and salmon sharks oh their
success - another surprising trait warm
blood inside a cold-blooded creature
inside their bodies they have bundles of
arteries and veins called RET mirabile
II here venous blood warmed up by the
sharks working muscles passes right next
to arteries carrying cold oxygen-rich
blood from the gills
this arrangement transfers heat to the
blood that gets cycled back to the
body's vital organs warmer muscles
enable faster more powerful swimming
while warmer bellies aid digestion and
the more rapid development of young in
utero and warmer eyes and brains keep
the Sharks alert in cold waters with
these amazing adaptations there's more
to revere than fear from the 500 shark
species roaming our ocean unfortunately
one third of these species are
threatened due to overfishing after
millions of years in the making these
apex predators may be meeting their
greatest challenge yet
you